in this case study we're going to
quickly look at how an image of your
apparatus could become an interesting
photograph to submit for a cover or used
as a figure here we're suggesting a
process now because I couldn't
photograph the experiment as always
going on because it was a closed system
I made an initial image of the apparatus
used in the research these wires are
heated to vaporize polymer material
which is then deposited onto chips as
you see here I first thought it would
make a nice image for a cover leaving
room for the journals logo as it turned
out that image was used for the MIT news
page I then decided to add another piece
of their apparatus to fill the whole
image in the end we did submit this one
for the cover but it didn't get it what
we did get was something called the
frontispiece in the journal and
surprisingly they preferred this
inverted image which I made just for fun
rather than the original frankly I
personally preferred the first one but
you know you just never know people's
tastes